[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE: Thank you,
everyone, for joining.
I'm pleased to introduce our
guest today, Ryan Williams.
He's the author,
keynote speaker,
and former stand up comedian.
So ask him some questions.
He's a funny guy and
apparently a good writer.
He authored his book, "The
Influencer Economy," which
is a top seller on Amazon,
and he teaches readers
how to launch their stories,
collaborate with influencers,
and thrive in the digital age.
Ryan's work has been featured
in "Inc." magazine, "Huffington
Post," "The Observer," "Business
Insider," and "USA Today."
He also has a podcast called
"The Influencer Economy," which
he can talk about, as well.
And then he was also on
the early social media
team at DigiSynd, which
was acquired by Disney,
and Machinima, acquired
for Warner Bros.
So thank you, Ryan,
for being here.
And he's also pretty
good at basketball,
and you can see him
shooting hoops over
at Venice High School
gym on Wednesday nights.
So with that, thank
you, Ryan, for joining.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN WILLIAMS: Thank you, Dave.
Hey, everyone.
How's it going today?
Just to give you
some background here,
Dave has a really
good reverse lay up
under the hoop at
the Venice High Gym
every Wednesday, which you can
feel free to come watch us.
We never have anyone
in the audience,
so it would be a complete shock.
And as Dave mentioned, I'm
a former stand up comedian.
So I wanted to ask you to give
yourselves a round of applause
for being out today.
[APPLAUSE]
You could be anywhere.
You watching at home,
thank you for tuning in.
And it's a little known fact.
When you do stand
up comedy, you may
notice that, when a
performer goes on stage
and you're in the crowd, the
comedian always says give it up
for the last performer.
And side note, you always want
to start off with applause,
because then if you
bomb, at the very least,
you felt good for five seconds
when you started your talk.
So I wrote the book "The
Influencer Economy--
How to Launch Your Idea,
Share it With the World,
and Thrive in the Digital Age."
So as I have been
researching influence
over the last few years, I've
understood that true influence
comes through collaboration.
And on the two ends
of the spectrum,
when you want to
think about influence,
there's being alone, building
in a garage, in a silo,
in your office,
and collaboration,
working with others.
And the more you collaborate--
or as they say in the
YouTube world, collab--
then that's where the
influence happens.
So today we'll be talking
about this on many levels,
and I'd love to get started
if you're all ready.
Grumpy Cat-- who here is not
familiar with Grumpy Cat?
So everyone here is aware
of Grumpy Cat, right?
Grumpy Cat is a meme.
Grumpy Cat looks
like a grumpy person,
and it was started on Reddit
thread many years ago.
This is the original
photo of Grumpy Cat,
and then it became
a large scale meme.
I went to South by Southwest
a couple of years ago.
There was a line of 75 people
to take selfies with Grumpy Cat.
Grumpy Cat-- little known
fact-- gets over $10,000
for appearance fees.
Another little known fact--
Grumpy Cat has a manager.
There is a meme
manager out there
that has Grumpy Cat
under its umbrella,
and Grumpy Cat looks
authentic, right?
And authenticity pays
in the digital economy.
So today, I'd love
to talk to you
about how to tell
your stories, how
to tell your bad ass stories.
At the end of the
talk, the last few
slides I'll be giving you
a framework for how do
you tell your bad ass stories.
So feel free-- if
you're watching at home,
get a pen and paper,
as well as in the crowd
here at Google, because I'm
giving you an actual framework
for telling bad ass stories
to help you get a promotion,
to help you generate
sales leads,
and to help you to launch
your business idea.
When talking about storytelling,
I realized through my podcast
I've collected
over 100 interviews
with some of the
top best selling
authors, globally
renowned YouTubers,
and amazing podcasters.
And I found that everyone needs
three stories in their pocket
at all times.
And most of us, the majority
of us, nearly all of us
undervalue our stories.
We let the boss tell our
story to their superior
and then wonder why we
didn't get that raise.
We think that our sales
rep understands the story
to close the deal,
but little do you
know that you've got no revenues
because the sales rep couldn't
pitch the business.
Or even worse, you think your
significant other gets you,
and you're surprised
when they're not
in your brain to
understand what you're
thinking when you're mad.
So the three stories that I'll
talk about today that everyone
needs in their pocket
are what I call
your underdog story,
your bad ass authority
story, and your fixer story.
The first story is the underdog.
Think about Rudy.
Think about walking
on to Notre Dame.
Think about having no
background in football,
and suddenly you're
on the field.
The underdog story is
when you're an outsider
and you become an insider.
It's when you have an
outsider perspective.
You're an underdog,
and you succeed.
David and Goliath is a
great example of this.
And all of us-- when I worked
for startups like Machinima
and DigiSynd that were acquired
by Warner Brothers and Disney,
all of our founders
had such great stories
about being the disruptor.
Google itself-- you all
acquire many companies,
and those startups often
have that outsider story.
They're raging against
the machine, if you will.
And Brene Brown is my example
for the bad ass authority
story.
Google Talks, TED Talks--
we all know people come
in to teach you something.
And a true word of
mouth marketing pro
will leave you with
three things to remember,
because things in our brain
process through three.
For example, I have
three bad ass stories.
That's for a reason--
because we process that way.
And a bad ass story, whether
it's a TED Talk or a Google
Talk, happens in a way where
we are showing our authority
by teaching, and instructing,
and giving people
something to remember.
They can tell their
spouse, their client
to refer you for business--
their co-founder.
And that's where true
authority comes from--
through instructing others.
And then finally, we have
Winston Wolfe from "Pulp
Fiction," and he's the fixer.
He helps do all the dirty work.
And your fixer story is when
you talk about solving problems
for other people, and that's
how, when you become a bad ass,
you don't mention six figures
and how much money you make.
A side note-- I went to
a dinner the other week,
and one of the guys next to
me-- it's always a guy, right?
I said, what do you do?
And he says, I make six figures.
And I wanted to just walk away
immediately, and drop my fork,
and spill my beer
on him, but then I
made the mistake of
asking a follow up.
And I said, how do you do that?
He said-- no joke--
I make six figures helping
business people who make
six figures make seven figures.
And I was just like,
oh my god, this
is the worst type
of person I want
to be around at a
networking event.
So that's not what a fixer is.
A fixer is someone
who solves problems.
A fixer is someone who actually
tells you who the customer is.
It's often like "Mad Libs."
I help people do blank.
I help people tell stories.
I help people learn how
to use Google AdSense.
I help people watching at home
to share videos on Facebook,
which I hope you
do with this video.
So everyone needs three bad
ass stories in their pocket
anytime anywhere.
I'm going to show you
how to do this later,
but in the meantime, let's
have an interactive part
of the talk.
This is my family
growing up circa 1992
in the blistering cold
winter of Des Moines, Iowa.
Now, just to have a
second here to pause,
is my family photo that went
out to all of our friends
that my mom posed
in our driveway--
see her wreath in the back?
She's very proud of that.
Is this authentic?
Do you think it's authentic?
You don't think it's-- a
hater in the front row.
I love these people.
I love when you get someone
who just says no right away,
and then you're like, all right.
So it's not authentic.
Why?
AUDIENCE: It's set up.
RYAN WILLIAMS: It's set up.
Right.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think the
expressions on the faces
are authentic.
RYAN WILLIAMS: The expressions
on the faces are authentic.
So you're not saying no,
but you're not saying yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
even if it's staged
you can't get kids to do exactly
what you want them to do.
So there's some element
of authenticity in it.
RYAN WILLIAMS: There's some
element of authenticity to it.
And do you know which one is me?
People sometimes get confused.
AUDIENCE: Middle.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Bottom left, no.
Middle, yes.
The bottom left is
my younger brother,
who looks like he took a
hockey puck to the face.
He has no teeth.
So is this authentic?
Again, please feel free to come
up to the front of the stage.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
RYAN WILLIAMS: You think so.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's got the kind
of lighthearted warm
feeling that you
get when something
kind of candid happens.
And candid is very authentic.
It's the expression of
the moment as it happened.
Whether this was staged
by your mom or not,
it was kind of an authentic
happening in that time.
RYAN WILLIAMS: So it's candid.
It's in the moment.
It's staged by my mom.
I have an authentic face.
I am an awkward middle child
still, and at that moment,
I was not self-aware
of who I was.
So my older brother
just cracked a joke
because the photographer,
Virginia, had backed up
and stepped in dog poop.
And my brother made a joke about
it, but he's a cool teenager.
So he knows that he's got
to have his game face on,
but I feel like I could be
the most authentic person here
because I'm laughing
at the joke.
But anyone else on
this side of the room?
Is this authentic?
And what do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
AUDIENCE: You always wore
red sweaters [INAUDIBLE]..
RYAN WILLIAMS: Always, always.
And you could see our breath.
It's so cold outside.
So when we all got pneumonia
afterwards, thanks, mom.
AUDIENCE: It's authentic
to me because it reminds me
of my own family photos that my
mom would've taken growing up.
So in my own point of
view, it looks authentic.
RYAN WILLIAMS: It
looks authentic
because she can relate to it,
because her family tortured her
through pleated khaki
pants, matching red sweaters
and turtlenecks in the
blistering cold of Iowa.
And anyone watching from
home on YouTube, please
leave a comment--
and I will interact with
everyone in the comments--
to tell me if my
family was authentic.
Because I think everyone
here was right in a way.
It's framed, which
seems inauthentic,
but our expressions
are authentic.
And meanwhile, I just kicked my
younger brother in the shins,
and he had punched me in the
stomach, and that's authentic.
You can't manufacture that
type of brotherly authenticity
around the world.
So again, please leave
a comment in YouTube
if you're watching
this because what
I call this is being
inauthentically authentic.
And as storytellers,
we all need to think
about how to be real when
telling our same story again,
and again, and again.
Who here works in sales?
How many times a day do
you pitch the same story?
A week, a month.
And you rehearse that story.
And we all need to
consider ourselves
that we work in sales,
and we're selling
ourself, because storytelling
can help you reinvent
your career, can help
you get that promotion,
and it can help you
launch your idea.
And it's not about
the elevator pitch.
We're not here to talk
into a confined elevator
where I get 20
seconds to pitch you.
I hate getting pitched.
Coming back to South by
Southwest, where I went--
I used to go every year.
People pitch you all the time,
and it's like clammy hands
central.
People talking to you-- they
give you business cards.
You throw a third of them
away, and ultimately people
don't know how to
network in a lot of ways,
because they think
they need to pitch you,
and they're only going
to get 30 seconds.
And if you can't get
a conversation going
with someone, it's not
worth telling a story.
I recommend that you
consider that, when
someone wants to hear your
story, you're collaborating.
And you want them to
opt in to your story.
You want them to reciprocate,
and you're not pitching them.
It's not a one way street,
because stories are connecting.
And I recommend everyone have a
20 minute conversational story.
And that's really--
I interviewed
a lot of Hollywood
screenwriters,
and Oscar nominated
directors, and people
that are working
in entertainment
that pitch studios.
And they said a 20 minute
conversational story
is the threshold
where you can actually
make a difference in Hollywood
to get someone's attention
to get that next
meeting or opportunity.
And when you think
about your storytelling,
you need to put yourself in
the other person's shoes.
My dad gave me great advice
when I was interviewing
for jobs after college.
And he says, when
you're in the interview,
don't let them ask
questions to you.
You need to ask
questions to them.
What's in it for them?
Everyone has a massive
ego, and people
love to talk about themselves.
So if you can hear
their stories--
I mean, how many times have
you walked away from a job
interview where you've said--
that person says,
I really liked you,
and all you did was to listen
to them the whole time,
and all they did was
talk about how great
they were, and all you
did was silently nod,
or say I want to hear more, or
say thank you for sharing that?
Because ultimately,
storytelling works both ways.
And when you're in the right
room at the right time,
you need to tell
different stories,
and you can't rely
on the same stories
over again because
people want to hear
different elements of
your life, and your story,
and your work at the right time.
So this is my story right now.
It's funny, because I got laid
off from a big corporation--
Disney.
And there's no photos on
Facebook of me depressed
at work getting laid off.
You don't capture that.
So I did a little freelancing
with my Photoshop skills,
and that's the parking lot where
I cried after getting laid off
from Disney.
And I was ashamed with my
box of belongings in my car,
not wanting to call my wife
for fear of what she'd say.
And I ended up going
to a Burbank taqueria
and drinking a margarita with
another guy who was laid off.
Ultimately, I got a better job.
Two weeks later I
started at Machinima.com,
which is a big YouTube partner.
And who here, just
out of curiosity,
has been fired or laid off?
Who here is not
telling the truth?
Who here just has had
the same job at Google
for their whole life?
One person.
Two people.
And if you're watching on
YouTube in the comments,
tell me if you've
been laid off or fired
and where you've been
laid off or fired,
because ultimately
we're all going
to be rejected in our life.
We're all going to go
through reinvention,
and for that moment in the
parking lot when I cried,
there's nothing better
than getting laid off,
getting severance, and then
finding a new job, getting
a raise, and double dipping.
For those of you that have been
laid off, when you double dip,
you feel like a pro.
You're like, I
worked the system.
I totally had this moment where
I failed, but then I succeeded.
In storytelling,
when we're bad asses
and we're trying to frame these
moments that we're authentic,
that failure really
can become a positive.
And so most of us
undervalue our stories.
The majority of people--
they truly undervalue
their stories,
because they're worried
about taking credit perhaps,
or they don't want
to be braggadocios,
or they don't want to
be inauthentic and seem
like they're cheesy
or too salesy.
And oftentimes,
these low moments
in our life, these underdog
moments when you rise up
are truly bad ass moments.
So when you have
your bad ass story--
and consider this as an
exercise with your customers,
with your network, or
with your peers at Google,
but you need to think
about your story audience.
And I don't recommend you
think about reaching everyone
with your stories.
I highly suggest
you think about 11%
of your customer base, your
network, or your community.
And I'll tell you
in a minute why,
but for starters, you have to
think about your collaborators.
Your collaborators are
10% of your network.
This is based initially and
inspired by an early 2000 study
about what made Wikipedia work.
And Wikipedia-- we all
use it to this day--
is actually only written
by 1% of internet users.
And 10% of the community
edits Wikipedia, and 89% of us
are lurkers.
So in this room, all
of us are lurkers.
And when you think about
telling your story,
presenting yourself
to the world,
talking about your business,
the collaborators--
these are the people that
I call your bar regulars.
They're your network.
They're your weak
ties that you maybe
met through an acquaintance
that can help you
open doors for new channels.
And they're the people that
organize the happy hour.
You come.
You bring Dave.
He brings three friends.
He brings his team from Google.
And then you spread your
word of mouth that way.
Whenever you're
looking for a job,
what's the first thing you do?
When I got laid off
by Disney, I hit up
Machinima, who was
a client of mine.
And I asked them if
they had openings?
It's funny, right?
When you get laid off, you
have to frame your story.
How do I say that I'm
in between opportunities
without saying that
they told me to go away?
And those collaborators
are the people
to prove your concept out.
And then there are
the influencers.
And I'm not talking
about Instagrammers
that get a bunch of likes, these
no talent zeros that look sexy
in blue jeans.
I'm not talking about these
one percenters on YouTube.
I'm talking about the
people that can make change
and that are game
changers for you
because they're able to
open doors, generate leads
for your business, make the
right connections for you
to further enhance your career.
And you need to think
about 11% of the community.
Who here watches YouTube videos
with professional YouTubers?
You subscribe to channels.
You watch the content.
They put it out consistently.
So the YouTube phenomenon
about collaboration--
it's called collabing.
Anyone here familiar
with that word.
I imagine people
watching on YouTube are.
So collabing is when you share
your story on another YouTubers
channel, and then they
come on your channel
to collab and share their story.
So who here has
a hobby that they
would be willing to pretend
like they had a YouTube
channel about?
You right there.
Do you have a hobby that
we could talk about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN WILLIAMS: Zero hobbies.
AUDIENCE: Zero hobbies.
RYAN WILLIAMS: And
you work at Google?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, very boring.
[INAUDIBLE]
RYAN WILLIAMS: Wow.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm and
illustrator and a painter.
RYAN WILLIAMS: So let's say you
have an illustration channel.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Alex.
RYAN WILLIAMS: So Alex has
Alex's paint guru YouTube
channel--
100,000 subscribers.
Anyone here into art, as well.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Khari.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Khari.
What kind of art?
AUDIENCE: Graffiti art.
RYAN WILLIAMS: What find of art?
AUDIENCE: Graffiti aft.
Yeah, that's great.
Can you talk to the guy next to
you to give him some hobbies?
That's a really cool hobby.
So we have a
YouTube channel here
with a million subscribers.
So Alex's graffiti channel--
and you all are going
to collab, which
means you're going to go
in each other's channels.
Even though your channel over
here has 100,000, that's OK.
It's a very focused community.
It's niche, and even though your
graffiti channel is very broad,
it doesn't matter.
The majority of
YouTubers are givers.
They want to open up
doors and channels,
and they want to lend
their influence to others.
And true collaboration
happens when
you're able to tell your
stories to other folks that
then can share your
story to their networks.
And as I mentioned
before, you want
to opt in with your stories.
You don't want to spam
people like you're
posting frictionless
information on Facebook.
If you can tell me a great
Facebook conversation
you have where you
change someone's mind,
I'll give you $100 on the spot.
But when you want to collaborate
with people, you opt in.
So the collab happens
where you make a video,
say, three minutes long.
You make a video
three minutes long.
You're in each other's videos.
They're separate videos.
They go to those
separate audiences,
and then you drive subscribers,
and likes, and community to one
another.
The million subscribed
graffiti channel--
you're opening up to a broad
audience with this 100,000
subscribed channel
over here, but you're
getting more of a niche
audience with this art channel.
And that's really how
the internet works,
and how you surface yourself
above the fray with your Amazon
book, your YouTube channel,
your Instagram page.
It's collabing.
So metaphorically
speaking, think
about that with your network.
There's a great book I
recommend called "Give and Take"
by Adam Grant, and
he was kind enough
to leave a blurb on
the back of my book.
He talks about givers,
and takers, and matchers.
And anyone familiar
with this book?
It's a great book, and
I recommend reading it
after you read my book.
And we can start a book
club if you'd like?
Ryan@influencereconomy.com
if you'd
like to join the book club,
and it will be global.
Ultimately, there's givers,
takers, and matchers.
Most of us are matchers, right?
You help me, I help
you-- survival.
Scratch my back, I'll
scratch your back.
And then there's the takers,
which we all have to work with,
which I think this guy over
here may be a taker because he
was very judgmental about
my family being inauthentic.
Sorry, not sorry.
And so takers you have
to work with, right?
And givers-- so givers are
people that succeed the most,
and they fail the most.
Giving with purpose
is how you succeed.
Giving with your own
self interests aligned
is how you succeed.
And that's where Adam's
research really comes into play.
So think about that with
your 10% collaborators.
So this is a globally
renowned TV host,
and you may not recognize Oprah.
This is back when her
show was only in Chicago
and not nationally syndicated.
And she's wearing extremely
tight skinny jeans.
And what I think
about authenticity
is it's when your
actions match your words.
On my podcast, I've talked
to some legendary authors,
and YouTubers, and people
with a lot of influence.
And I always ask them,
what is your definition
of authenticity?
And what I surmised is your
actions match your words.
And why Oprah is important here
is she skinnied herself down.
She lost 60-some pounds to
fit into these blue jeans.
She actually now
regrets this episode
because she didn't want her
to find her self worth through
whether or not she
could fit in blue jeans,
but ultimately she brought
out a bunch of fat and gristle
from a steak to show in a Ziploc
bag all the weight she lost.
What happened in that moment
was Oprah allowed people
into her story, and
true authenticity--
the ability to tell your
bad ass story, the ability
to grow yourself
and your work comes
from letting people
in to your story,
giving them behind the curtain.
If you make a mistake, it's OK
because don't worry about it.
We're all imperfect.
The second thing about
Oprah that I love
is she thought about
her story audience,
and she had an avatar,
a character in her mind
that she had is a
Midwest housewife, Susie.
So she said, what's
in it for Susie?
What will Susie get
out of the show?
What will Susie take
away from this episode?
And every episode she
did was for Susie.
So think about when you're
telling your story-- you're
in a sales pitch
at Google, working
in trying to get a new client.
Who is your Susie?
Put yourself in their
shoes, and what story
can you collaborate
on to share with them?
And finally, true
collabing happens
when you work with others
to share platforms,
and opportunities,
and connections.
She really took
off to superstardom
when Meryl Streep, the Bush's,
the Obamas, Tom Hanks--
all these A-list celebrities
came on her show,
and they became able to grow
their platform and hers.
She really collaborated
with influencers.
So you think about this
in context of your work.
Try to find the Oprah
of your business.
None of us will be the Oprah
of our business necessarily,
but find those influencers
to present our story
to that really can
move the needle
like she does for other people.
So these are your
three bad ass stories--
the underdog, the bad
ass, and the fixer.
So a story that connects
you to an emotional level
is the underdog, specifically
when you overcame an obstacle.
The bad ass displays
your expertise
in your specific field that
you can teach others about.
And finally, the fixer--
it shares a problem
you're solving
with a current customer, or it
presents your business thesis
or vision.
The underdog story--
I want to tell you about your
bad ass story as an underdog--
Rocky, Philadelphia-- anyone
here from Philadelphia?
Back there, right?
Champion of the underdog.
Eagles just won the Super Bowl.
Ultimate underdog story.
Rocky-- and Sylvester
Stallone-- a little known fact--
he packaged the deal.
He wrote the screenplay
for "Rocky"-- did you all
know this?
And he said, I'm only going
to do it if I act in it,
and he turned down
money, and other roles,
and opportunities
because he wanted to act.
And so he was an
underdog himself.
But the underdog story is
when you're the outsider--
to pitch yourself,
present yourself,
and you succeeded in
the end, or your thrived
because you created that
opportunity like an underdog.
I used to call this
story your tear jerker,
but it got a little too
emotional for people
because not everyone wants to
talk about emotional moments.
Because-- little known fact--
I was a stand up
comedy performer
and simultaneously going
through clinical depression.
And I will let you be
the judge if I was funny
or not as a depressed
stand up comedian,
but that is really where
I overcame my obstacle.
I call it my jumping out
of an airplane moment.
I was able to put myself out
there and feel the response
from the audience,
and it really helped
me reframe my life to position
myself more in marketing.
Realizing that-- who
here likes Public Enemy?
There's Chuck D, and
there's Flavor Flav.
And what I realized is
sometimes you're the lyricist,
like Chuck D, and
sometimes you're
the hype man, like Flavor Flav.
And we all go back and forth--
hype man to lyricist,
lyricist to Flavor Flav.
So think about that
as you collaborate
and reach your moments of
sharing your underdog story.
And the bad ass story--
that is what the stage is for.
Every Google Talk, every TED
Talk-- it's a bad ass story.
I've studied hundreds of them.
What I realized was many of
them start with a tear jerker
and then roll into
the bad ass authority.
Like, oh I'm an introvert.
Let me tell you how
I'm introverted,
and let's tell you the
secret of introverts.
Let me tell you
how I asked people
for money begging on the
street, and now here I
am talking about
asking for things
and how you can do
it for yourself.
So the crux of this
story is Brene Brown.
Anyone familiar with her work?
She talks a lot
about authenticity,
and she's a shame expert.
And she talks about how
shame's on this spectrum,
and authenticity is
on the other spectrum.
How's everyone
doing, by the way?
How are we doing at home?
If you are paying attention
on YouTube, like this video.
Then they'll let me know if
there's 1,000 likes, but Brene
Brown-- she talks about
shame and authenticity,
and how we're all built
to not talk about shame.
And so her TED Talk,
and her Google Talks,
many books she's written
are all about those topics.
And she's an expert in it.
She's done years of research.
So she teaches you something.
Hopefully today
you could take away
one thing or three things
with your bad ass stories
to bring to your
teams, your spouse,
your significant others.
And Celeste Headlee, who's
given a Google Talk, as well,
and many TED Talks--
she talks about how
to have better conversations.
She's in the red dress up there.
I interviewed her on my
podcast, was a remarkable guest.
I find the best podcast
guests are fellow podcasters
or authors because they
know how to frame a story,
and the worst are tech founders.
No offense.
I don't want to hear about
going to Stanford and building
a company in your
garage, or how it's--
like raising venture capital,
or what your product does,
because unfortunately
that doesn't
relate to 99% of the country.
And Celeste Headlee
talks about--
sorry to bash tech founders in
the room, but Celeste Headlee--
she says there's three ways
to tell stories and converse,
and they come across
through body language,
through vocabulary, and
through physical language.
And so email is
really inefficient,
because I only get
your vocabulary.
And picking up the
phone's much better.
Who here works in
sales and knows
to close you call
because you get the tone?
And finally, body
language-- that's
why we want to meet
people in person.
And the fixer story--
Olivia Pope, the ultimate
fixer, Winston Wolfe
from "Pulp Fiction,"
the ultimate fixer.
Who here watches "Scandal"
or has seen "Pulp Fiction?"
So the majority of the room
in America has most likely.
So the fixer is, how am I
solving problems for people?
And not how much money I make,
not six figures guy or gal.
And definitely not what
your client base is.
That can help sometimes
for some social proof,
but you want to say I
help people do blank.
Think about the
context of what you do
based on how you help others.
So Dave, how would you
frame your work based
on I help people do blank?
DAVE: I help companies
better understand
what's going on in their
website so that they
can sell more
product to users that
find it valuable and helpful.
RYAN WILLIAMS: So Dave
helps people understand
their website, and
he's making you more
money in the long run, right?
Dave, I'll write you
a check right now.
That was a great sales pitch.
So when you think about your
context of how you help others,
it's often based on
I'm providing value,
and I'm not going to
give you a dollar amount,
or I'm not going to
show you-- you all
know these YouTubers that
talk about in their garage
and their Ferraris.
They talk about
how rich they are.
The whole self-help business
world is all about, oh,
I got laid off from my job, and
my girlfriend broke up with me,
and then I made a bunch
of money on LinkedIn.
Those are not true
bad ass stories,
because if you tell me that
you have to make money,
then you're not a bad ass.
Sorry.
So think about also the
truth in what you do,
and we're going to go a
couple more slides here,
and then we'll get into
the framework for how
to tell the bad ass stories.
So find the truth
in what you do.
Who here has studied
improvisation?
We're based in LA.
There's a lot of comedy here.
Del Close is a great
improviser based out
of Second City, which
many "Saturday Night Live"
castmates have come from.
And they talk about
the truth in what you
do when you're doing improv.
True humor as a storyteller
isn't when you have punchlines.
How many of you
have told a story
where you thought it was really
funny and no one laughed?
And then you're like,
oh, that's really--
yeah, I'm going to leave
the room right now.
Exit stage left because
you didn't laugh.
True humor comes out of stories
when you have a funny story,
and you have moments
where people could laugh,
and if they don't laugh, then
you move on with yourself.
So we all have great
stories, and you
want to bring people
in, introduce conflict,
let them often figure
out the final answers.
Using myself as a Guinea pig, I
mentioned I did stand up comedy
while I was depressed, and I let
you be the judge if I was funny
or not.
Half the room probably thought
I was a typical comedian.
Other half probably thought
I was a walking zombie,
but you don't have
to solve conflicts.
And always be aware
of how awesome
you are, how much of
a bad ass you are,
and think about the word choice.
And this is my father-in-law.
Who here is married,
and has an in-law,
and knows how complicated those
types of relationships are?
So my father-in-law has
a boiler repair company
in North Carolina.
I live in California.
And he wants to know what
the influencer economy is,
and what Machinima is, and
what YouTube videos do,
and how these startups
that have so much value
don't make any money.
These are obvious questions
that we should answer,
but with him I
asked him, you know,
what is your secret as a boiler
repair operator and owner
in Raleigh, North Carolina?
He says, you've got
to solve pain points.
So when you think
about your storytelling
to pitch your business,
yourself, or your work,
what is the pain point
your story is solving.
How boring are you if you're
listening to someone talk--
or you're on the receiving
end of a story with no point?
So what are you solving
for that person?
Do they want to laugh?
Do they want to
hear you so they can
help you and tell their friends
that you need a new job?
Do they want to become someone
who's buying your product
and increase your sales?
And he says that he was very
good at developing a knowledge
or skill that he could tell
people just enough about to fix
their boiler, but
not enough that they
could do it on their own.
Joe Moore over there,
father-in-law--
father-in-law of the year
if you're watching, Joe.
And so he talked about how
the boilers are-- people--
an industry where they think
they can do it themselves.
How many of you all
have clients in sales
that they think they
can not hire you,
and then you give them
a little information,
a free consultation,
and a phone call,
and then they call
you up a week later?
Oh my god, I need you
to optimize my website.
I totally want to make more
money, and I dropped the ball.
We're now losing money.
So he talks about you've got to
develop this knowledge or skill
and then share it
with people, which
why all these principles,
through collaboration
and influence, are
available online and offline
for all of us.
This isn't just an
online marketing program.
And empathy-- over
the last year,
many CEOs and executives
at large corporations
have talked about
the need for empathy.
And with our online world
becoming very negative
at times, with our culture
at times being cynical,
and with our
leadership being driven
by the bottom line
at companies, empathy
is important across the board.
It's no longer going to
be just a nice to have.
It will be a must have.
And I interviewed Billy
Ray, who is a screenwriter.
He wrote "Hunger Games,"
was nominated for an Oscar.
And he told me when he
pitches in Hollywood
he needs to figure out what's
in the other guy's shoes.
The other guy in the table,
the other gal in the table--
what kind of shoes
are they wearing?
What do they want to hear?
And I want you to have empathy
for the other people you're
talking to when you
present your story,
and more importantly,
have empathy for yourself,
because we are so judgmental
about our own stories.
And we're so judgmental about
how we present ourselves.
I sometimes hate
listening to my podcast--
and I am a podcaster--
because I can't stand
to hear my voice.
So many of us don't
like to watch ourselves
talk because we say like, or
um, or modifiers to not say
what we want to say.
So have empathy as you think
about your bad ass stories.
So these are the
three bad ass stories
that Grumpy Cat is going
to help us to write now.
So you watching at
home or you here today,
you all can hopefully have
takeaway value immediately.
So number one of three things.
Create a mind map.
Anyone here done
a mind map before.
A mind map is very good to
visualize problems you have.
I recommend creating a visual
representation of what you're
trying to do, and
having branches
and connected topics that
remind you of your stories.
So the central idea
is, what's important?
Being a bad ass.
And I did this online.
It's very easy.
There's many mind
mapping programs.
I also do them by
hand, and I wanted
to not edit this
professionally because this
is how raw our stories are.
And many of us don't think
we have great stories.
You could be watching this on
YouTube and think I'm only 18.
I don't have any
stories yet, and that's
where the undervalued
stories come into play.
So this is, like I mentioned, I
sometimes call the tear jerker
story, now the underdog.
And so this is where I
went through to figure out
how to map my story.
And I had a client who is
based out of Minnesota,
and he did this mind map when
he quit a pre-ROTC program,
and he had lived with
shame in his life.
And he told me figuring
out how to story edit what
happened allowed him to present
his failure with confidence.
And so when I went
through with my underdog--
I was laid off.
You see that point.
I mentioned that story.
I talked about how I
had shame with my wife.
I talked about how
I cried in my car.
I went to drink margaritas,
but I found a better job.
So I'm bringing this
together in a way
to help you understand that
having empathy for yourself
allows you to understand
that many of these negatives
can be positives.
You talk about I was
promoted and demoted
at Machinima, which
is whole other story.
Over beers we can talk about it.
My stand up comedy career--
I was a film career lackey.
I was a PA.
I sound like an existential
crisis guy, right?
I've done film.
I've done comedy, and
now I do marketing,
but ultimately I was
depressed in my 20s.
And then here's
another mind map.
If you want to really
make it more structured,
I recommend mind
mapping your stories.
So if you have a sales pitch,
and you have five stories,
and you want to figure
out which ones help,
this is a great
organizational tool.
This is my bad ass story.
And I talk about I'm
a public speaker.
I think that's an
accomplishment.
I ran marketing at
Machinima, and I
talk about all the
things I did there.
I performed stand
up comedy 50 times.
And again, using myself
as the Guinea pig here,
this is how you figure
out what to tell people.
And it's a framework
that makes you understand
the elements of your
story, because you're
going to lose focus
sometimes telling your story,
and you may not remember.
So I can look at this mind map
right now before I give a talk
and understand the
points I need to hit.
So the second point--
develop five headlines.
Think of yourself as
a blogger, a YouTuber,
someone creating content.
What are your headlines?
Talk about in
those headlines how
you displayed an
expertise in your field
because you're a bad ass.
Something you could teach others
to help grow your influence
and help them grow theirs--
to make an emotional connection.
And then more
important, you want
to collab with people
to create word of mouth
so they could
remember three things,
or at the very least, one thing.
If you walk out here
today, I failed if you
can't remember one thing.
Hopefully you remember
three bad ass stories,
and if you didn't,
then I need to go back
to the drawing board.
So let's just all assume you're
remembering all of this stuff.
And so and then you
write your headlines.
You practice them.
And you take your friends,
talk to your family,
your colleagues.
Think about creating
a trust group.
I always recommend having
accountability friends.
If you work at a company that's
small, you're an entrepreneur.
And find the headlines
that are really compelling.
Go bold, go big, and mash
them up if they don't work.
And so these are my
bad ass headlines.
I performed stand up comedy 500
times, including the improv.
I overcame clinical
depression in my 20s.
And if you notice, I mash
those two headlines up,
because on their own, those
stories aren't compelling.
And I don't tell that
story to everyone,
because not everyone
I meet for 20 minutes
needs to know that I
struggle through depression.
There are stigmas to it.
Laid off by Disney.
Cried in my car.
Got a better job in two weeks.
Launched a podcast.
Wrote my book.
So I don't want to just
get into all these moments
because true bad asses don't
talk about how bad ass they
are, right?
But that's where you
need to go with this,
and think about the stories
framing you in a way
that you're showing people.
You're not telling people.
That's when great scripts
are written in Hollywood
that show rather than tell.
And if you create a metaphor,
or a visual representation,
or an example that resonates--
even acronyms work.
I imagine at Google you
have many, many acronyms
to help people remember.
So my final bad ass headline--
after a corporate layoff,
I joined Machinima.com.
Our team launched the
video game "Minecraft"
before its $2.5 billion exit.
If I talk to anyone
in the world,
they've heard of "Minecraft."
My book is coming out in
Korean later this year,
and everyone there
loves "Minecraft."
So that resonates.
And I don't tell you--
I was not the founder
of the company.
I ran the marketing campaign.
So most of us understand that
we do really awesome things.
We truly do bad ass
things, memorable things.
And you could be a smaller
piece of a larger pie,
and that's where I found
most people undervalue
their stories.
They don't to take credit.
They have some sort
of imposter syndrome
where they don't
feel like they--
how many of you feel like you
don't belong telling stories
because you're not the
one that did all the work?
And so that's where
the undervalue happens,
and you can take
something small that you
did that was memorable, and
impactful, and had influence,
and share that with others.
And don't be afraid
to be a bad ass.
And then finally,
the third thing.
So we can mind map our ideas.
We write five headlines is
the second element of this.
The third thing is
write 20 minutes each.
There's a study out of
UT-Austin that, when something's
bothering you, if you write
20 minutes of free thought
about it and don't
even look at it again,
it will ease your mind.
How many of you use
voice-text recognition?
You're driving in the car
to remember something,
and it makes you feel
better because you're not
going to forget
it even though you
forgot that you recorded it.
That happens to me all the time.
And if you don't feel
comfortable writing speech
to text, create a
video of yourself
and think about how
to transcribe it.
Even if you want to
package together,
write a blog post about it, hire
and editor, because a lot of us
don't have empathy
for our own stories,
and we may be self-conscious.
But getting that feedback from
other people could be helpful.
And as we close up here,
I want to hearken back
to my comedy days.
This is the improv in Washington
DC, where I performed.
And I got some great advice from
a lot of different comedians,
including Mitch Hedberg, who,
if you're on YouTube right now,
you should watch his videos.
He's hilarious.
And his advice to me was
always finish your set
and never get let the audience
get in the way of finishing
your jokes.
So when you tell your
stories, have a set order.
Don't freestyle.
The best comedians that do
crowd work and they make
fun of people in the crowd
have scripted that most likely.
And they've practiced
it at open mic nights.
And they go to open mics before
they headline the improv.
And think about every comedian--
if you notice, they have
a beer, a glass water,
and a little note card on
stage, or they use a coaster,
and they have their
set list because they
want to remember the order.
And I recommend not free
styling your jokes--
I'm sorry, not free
styling your stories,
because great comedians don't
freestyle, don't improvise.
I want go see Seinfeld, Chris
Rock, whomever, Chris Tucker,
and hear their best jokes.
I don't want to hear their
new jokes that aren't funny,
that aren't well rehearsed.
So people want to
hear great stories.
And don't be afraid, or
ashamed, or feel vulnerable
if you tell the same
story again and again.
And ultimately, think about
comedians and how well
rehearsed they are.
And in sales especially,
you all know that.
You've got to have it
down, the same pitch, over
and over again.
So coming back full
circle to my corporate guy
turns layoff into
career reinvention,
we're all reinventing
ourselves right now.
If we haven't been laid off
now, we know friends that have.
If we haven't been fired yet,
we know friends that have.
That was really morbid.
I said yet.
None of you will get fired.
It's an easy world out here.
You're all millennials,
Generation Z. Don't worry,
it's not hard.
But when I was laid off in
the parking lot, I'm crying.
Tears are-- but I'm
quietly crying right
because I don't want
anyone to see me.
I have my box of belongings.
I'm nervous to call
my wife because I'm
ashamed of this failure.
And then like I said,
I felt like a bad ass
because I got a severance,
and a better job, and a raise.
And I wouldn't be on the stage
if I didn't get laid off.
So when you tell that
story as a bad ass,
don't be afraid to
own those low moments.
I got great advice
from a friend when
I was hesitant to
talk about depression.
I still am because
it's stigmatized.
And I only talked about it
once in front of an audience
because my friend said you
went through that moment.
You're not trying
to exploit this.
You're owning how you felt.
So when you have those negative
failures, the moments where
you don't succeed, we
all turn those into wins
because we're all here.
We're all in the room.
I'm on stage.
You're in the crowd.
You're watching it online.
So think about that
as you leave today
when you write your
three bad ass stories
and you have your
framework for three ways
to write those bad ass
stories, because all of us
are underdogs.
We're all bad ass authorities.
And ultimately, all
of us are fixers,
and we help people
solve problems.
Thank you so much for
having me today at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE: Thank you, Ryan.
And we do have a few
minutes for questions
if we have any questions
from the group.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Yeah?
You're my favorite audience
member, by the way.
You're overwhelming me.
AUDIENCE: So if you
have an idea and you've
been festering with this
idea for a period of time,
what is the pivotal
starting point?
Other than writing it
down and talking to close
trusted individuals about it--
RYAN WILLIAMS: Collaborators.
AUDIENCE: It's finding
the collab-- finding
somebody who is willing to jump
in the boat with you basically?
RYAN WILLIAMS: The
collaborators, yeah.
And realize not everyone's going
to want to jump in the boat,
but you're going to have to
find the collaborators that
opt in to wanting to hear more.
And if you're a lone wolf by
yourself and working alone,
you have to figure
out the right people
to trust to talk about
your problems with,
and that's most likely not going
to be your significant other,
spouse, or boyfriend
if they don't
work in the same industry.
And so going to meet ups
and sizing people up--
we live in LA, where everyone's
looking for a quick deal.
It's really hard to
sort through the noise.
You go to a networking
event, and everyone's just
a random jabroni, and you
have to fight through that
to find people that are real.
And so I always recommend--
if you have a story or an
idea, and you use a mind map,
and then you write
headlines about it,
and then you have a story to
tell people, hone that story
and really talk to
the right people.
And getting back to one of
the inspirations for the book
is influencers.
If you have a startup--
and I interviewed Brad
Feld for the book, who
started Techstars, and he
invested in Fitbit early.
And he's doing obviously very
well for himself, a big mentor.
And he has a lot of pull.
So why would you
go to him first?
He's an influencer.
He's a one percenter.
So you want to find those
10 percenter collaborators.
And realize you may
have to sift people,
and you can't treat
it like speed dating.
This isn't Tinder.
You're not looking for
a fast opportunity.
You're looking for-- see how I
thought about that before what
I said?
You want to think
about a longer term--
so I also think making a bigger
vision, a three year vision--
where do you want to go?
Who do you want to
collaborate with?
How do you get there?
And I'll tell a quick story.
So I met this guy Nir
Eyal through my podcast.
He wrote a really good
book called "Hooked--
How to Build
Habit-Forming Products,"
which after you read
"The Influencer Economy,"
and "Give and Take,"
and "Hooked"--
with our book club
that we're forming.
Again,
Ryan@influencereconomy.com
will make this global.
His book "Hooked"-- I wanted
to have him in my podcast.
I sent him a cold email.
Had a great headline.
I spent some time crafting it.
I met him.
We talked.
I ended up doing the
infamous airport ride.
If anyone offers you,
hey, I'm really busy,
can you pick me up
from the airport?
Do it.
There's so many stories
in Silicon Valley
where someone met someone
through an airport ride.
So I went, picked him
up from the airport,
collaborated on my podcast.
He spoke in my Prius in front
of a co-working space in Santa
Monica--
very LA-- and made
great content.
And then he went to speak
in front of 300 people
with his book behind him.
He then wrote a
book blurb for me.
We've collaborated
on other projects,
and it was all
through a cold email,
but I didn't go to Nir for guest
number one, or book blurber
number one, or book
subject expert number one.
I built my base.
I had 25 podcast episodes.
I had been doing it for a year.
I also was an
early adopter, so I
did podcasting before it
really became mainstream.
And so think about
that, your strategy.
So many great ideas
the because they
have the wrong collaborators.
And it's really your
integral launch opportunities
come through that team
of people to collab with.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Thank you.
That's a great question.
DAVE: Any other questions?
RYAN WILLIAMS: Do
you have a question?
No.
You have a question?
DAVE: All right,
well thanks to Ryan.
RYAN WILLIAMS:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]